AMY QUISPE: Hello world.
My name is Amy Quispe.
ERIC LEICHTENSCHLAG: And
I'm Eric Leichtenschlag.
AMY QUISPE: And
we're here with you
today from the Mobile Ads
Developer Relations Team.
Today we'll talk about migrating
to Google Play Services.
What Google Play Services
is, why you should migrate,
and the nitty gritty of
actually changing your code
from the old AdMob app to your
new Google Play Services app.
ERIC LEICHTENSCHLAG:
So first I'm
going to talk about what
is Google Play Services
and why you should
upgrade your AdMob
apps to use Google
Play Services.
So Google Play
Services is an APK
that's distributed through
the Google Play Store.
It gives you access to the
latest and greatest Google
Android APIs.
And now the APIs are part
of Google Play Services.
And the great advantage of using
the Google Play Services APIs
is that devices with
the Google Play Store
can get updates to the
library without you
having to re-release your app.
So if you push your app with
version one of Google Play
services with AdMob in it, and
AdMob makes changes and pushes
out a v2 onto those devices,
your app will start running v2
and take advantage of the
latest fixes to the library.
AMY QUISPE: So you should
update to Google Play Services
because you will get
these automatic platform
updates, which will
be a huge advantage.
We'll also just give
you better APIs.
We've totally revamped
a lot of the APIs
to do things the Android way.
Hopefully you'll find them
better and more intuitive.
And then this will
also be the platform
of choice going forward.
So we won't continue to iterate
on the standalone AdMob SDK.
But all of our new changes will
go to the Google Play Services
library.
So we hope that you can upgrade
so you can keep with the latest
updates that we have.
ERIC LEICHTENSCHLAG:
So now we're
going to talk about how to
migrate from the old library
to the new Google
Play Services APIs.
So previously, when
integrating a library,
you just had a jar and you would
put that jar into the libs/
folder for AdMob
6.4.1 and below.
In Google Play
Services you actually
have to integrate the Google
Play Services library project
and then reference that
project into your application.
So there's a difference there.
And then you'll also be using
the com.google.android.gms.ads
namespace when referencing
on the classes instead
of the com.google.ads namespace.
AMY QUISPE: When you
declare an AdActivity
in your manifest
XML, then you'll
also have to make a
few minor changes.
First you'll be
changing the namespace
from
com.google.ads.AdActivity to
com.google.android.gms.ads.AdActivity.
Again, we'll be changing that
namespace all across your app.
The other thing is you'll
have to add this metadata
tag for the Android
Play Services version.
So you'll use
com.google.android.gms.version
and import the Play
Services version.
Also, it's important
to note that all
of your permissions
and everything else
will stay the same.
So you don't have to worry about
that when updating your app.
ERIC LEICHTENSCHLAG:
So now I'm going
to talk about
creating an AdView.
So in AdMob 6.4.1, when
you created the AdView
in the constructor, you'd
pass the activity context,
the AdSize, and your AddUnitID.
In Google Play
Services, we're doing it
the Android way, where
a view object only
needs to take the
activity context.
So you just create a new AdView
with your activity context.
And then there are setAdUnitID
and setAdSize methods
to set the ad size and
pass your AdUnitID.
Note that these should
only be called once.
If you do it again you'll get
an illegal state exception.
But there should
be no reason you'd
have to call it more than once.
AMY QUISPE: When you
create an AdRequest,
you will no longer be
creating this AdRequest
and then adding a test device
or doing these other changes
directly to the AdRequest.
Instead we've moved to
the builder paradigm,
so you'll create an
AdRequest builder.
Everything you'll do will
be done to this builder.
The builder is an
immutable object,
so everything you do
to it will actually
be creating a new builder.
So you won't be
able to mess things
up in the middle of
running your application.
And then once you've actually
made all of your changes
to the builder, for example
adding a test device,
then you actually
build a builder
to create the AdRequest.
ERIC LEICHTENSCHLAG: You should
also note that the identifier
to get test ads on
emulators changed from
AdRequest.TEST_EMULATOR to
AdRequest.DEVICE_ID_EMULATOR.
AMY QUISPE: So next we'll talk
about creating a new AdListener
object.
So we changed the
AdListener object.
Previously in the standalone
SDK the AdListener object
was an interface so you
would extend your ad activity
with this AdListener object and
implement all of these methods
in order to track
what's going on.
Now in the new Google
Play services version,
we have an abstract class.
And you'll be able to actually
just create an AdListener
object on the fly, override
the methods that you need,
and leave all the rest alone.
One thing to note is that
we've changed the error code.
So now the error code
is just an integer,
and you'll have to create
a new method in order
to extract meaning
from that integer.
The other thing is
that we've changed
all of the names of the methods.
So onReceiveAd is
now onAdLoaded,
onFailedToReceiveAd is
now onAdFailedToLoad.
And all of these changes
are just one to one.
It shouldn't be difficult to
change from one to the other.
And then all of the
methods name will
be more consistent with the
Android way of doing things.
ERIC LEICHTENSCHLAG:
So now I'm going
to talk about the
implementation of an AdListener
and setting it on the adView.
So when we had the
interface, your class
that implemented
the AdListener would
have to implement all
of the ad event methods
in that interface.
And then finally call
adView.SetAdListener
with the object that
implemented the AdListener.
In Google Play Services,
we use an abstract class.
And so you can actually just
call adView.SetAdListener
and create a new AdListener
in line like a subclass
and just override the ad
events that you care about.
So in this example, we have
onAdLoaded and onAdFailedToLoad
implemented, but we
don't have to implement
the rest of the methods here.
AMY QUISPE: Next, we'll
talk about creating
an adView in XML.
Previously you were
able to do everything
in XML if you wanted to
have a very simple adView.
Now we'll have to actually
write a little bit of code.
But first, let's talk about
the changes in the XML.
So the main changes
in the XML are
that you won't be able to use
ad testDevices and ad load
on create in your XML.
So you'll have to add a
test device in the code.
And you also won't
be able to just load
an ad on create in the XML.
You'll have to remove
those attributes.
The other thing to notice is
that you'll have to change
your namespace from
apk/lib/com.google.ads
to apk/res-auto.
That's all going to
be auto imported.
Eric's going to talk to you
about the changes in the code.
ERIC LEICHTENSCHLAG: Yep, so the
change in the code for the XML
AdView in Google Play Services
is you'll have to grab
the AdView from the XML, create
a new AdRequest via the builder
pattern, and call loadAd
with that AdRequest .
As Amy mentioned,
in 6.4.1, there
is actually no code required if
you had used the LoadAdOnCreate
attribute to be true.
But also note that if you want
to do anything more complicated
like set an AdListener,
you'll still
need to write some code in both
either 6.4.1 or Google Play
services, and that
hasn't changed.
AMY QUISPE: Now we'll talk about
the adView lifecycle methods.
So previously in
the standalone SDK,
we only had adView.destroy().
Now we have adView.destroy(),
adView.pause()
and adView.resume().
These methods all allow you
to destroy, pause, or resume
web view.
So this gives you a
little bit more control
over what's actually going
on in your lifecycle.
ERIC LEICHTENSCHLAG:
So now I'm going
to talk about passing
Extras to AdMob.
You can do things like
set the background color
and text of your ad.
And that would be
done through Extras.
So in 6.4.1, you would
create the new AdRequest,
you'd create a new
AdMobAdapterExtras object,
and pass the call addExtra
and pass key value pairs,
for like background color
and text for example.
And then call setNetworkExtras
with that object.
In Google Play Services, it's
done a little bit differently.
You have an AdMobExtras instead
of an AdMobAdapterExtras.
And it accepts a
bundle, which have
to create before you create
the AdMobExtras class.
So you create a new bundle, put
string on your key value pairs,
create the AdMobExtras
object, and then finally when
you're creating the AdRequest
using the builder pattern,
you just call addNetworkExtras
with those Extras and build it.
AMY QUISPE: So we know
we've made a lot of changes
to the SDK.
So there's been a
couple questions.
We're going to address three
of the most frequently asked
questions.
The first one is, does
Google Play Services
support existing
mediation adapters?
The answer is yes.
We've made sure that none of
your mediation should break.
So if you upgrade to
Google Play Services today,
all of your mediation
should work as expected.
The mediation adapters
will be the same
for a long time in the future
if we do it right on mediation
and expect to mediation
adapters to update.
We still plan on
supporting legacy mediation
for quite a while in the future.
ERIC LEICHTENSCHLAG: The
next question guys have had
is, will Google Play
Services APIs work on devices
without Google Play
Services installed?
And it does.
The only difference
is that you won't
get to take advantage
of the auto updates.
So if you push your app
onto a Kindle that's
using the ads APIs in
Google Play Services,
that app won't get any
updates if Google Play pushes
a new version of the AdMob
lib APIs in the Google Play
Services library.
But for devices that do have
Google Play Services installed,
it will automatically
get those updates
and be running against the
latest version of our library.
AMY QUISPE: The last question
is if Google Play services
is compatible with the
old standalone AdMob SDK.
The answer is no, unfortunately.
This was a side effect of
trying to keep mediation
compatible with the new SDK.
However, you should
expect DFP and search
ads for apps and
everything else now
in new Google Play Services SDK.
So you shouldn't lose
any of that functionality
and should be able
to upgrade everything
to Google Play Services.
The other thing is if you are
working with a library that's
dependent on the
old SDK, then we
hope that you can merge those
library developers to upgrade
to the new Google Play
Services, since that's
where we'll be pushing
all updates from now on.
ERIC LEICHTENSCHLAG: So we've
given you a lot of information,
and it might take some
time for it to sink in.
Here are some more
resources that you
can use if you have
more questions.
So first you should check
out the Google Play Services
set up, because that explains
how to get Google Play Services
library into your app
so you can reference it.
And then if you want to
reference anything else that we
talked about today, you can
check out the Google Play
Services migration guide.
It has a lot of the
same information.
AMY QUISPE: And if you
have any trouble upgrading,
you can always hit up me
and Eric on the forums.
You can also talk to
other AdMob developers
there and see if they've had
the same troubles that you have.
We hope that this
has been helpful,
and we hope that you can enjoy
the new version of the AdMob
SDK.
Thank you.
ERIC LEICHTENSCHLAG:
Thanks guys.